MEMBERS OF THE SENATE IS CALLED
TO ORDER WITH THE SECRETARY.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALAN
ALBARADO GIL. ARCHULETTA. ASHBY.
ATKINS. BECKER. BLAKE SPEAR.
BRADFORD. CABALLERO. ORTEZ E.
DELI. DODD. SO EGGMAN. GLASER
GONZALES. GROVE. TODD Ó. JONES.
LAYERED LEMON. MCGUIRE MENJIVAR.
MEN. NEWMAN. WHEN HELLO. BUT THE
PORTANTINO ROTH. RUBIO. SO YOUR
TOE SKINNER. SMALLER CUEVAS.
STERN. HAMBURG. AHA! WIENER.
WELCOME. GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS.
A QUORUM IS PRESENT WITH THE
MEMBERS IN OUR GUESTS BEYOND THE
RAIL AND IN THE GALLERY, PLEASE
RISE. WILL BE LED IN PRAYER THIS
AFTERNOON BY SENATOR DURAZO,
AFTER WHICH PLEASE REMAIN
STANDING FOR THE PLEDGE OF
ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG. SENATOR
JERAS OH, THANK YOU, MR
PRESIDENT, AS WE BEGIN THE WORK
OF THIS WEEK, LET US PRAY AND
GRATITUDE FOR EACH OTHER AND FOR
ALL WHO WORK AT AND FOR THE
STATE CAPITAL. LET US DEDICATE
OUR WEEK TO THE PRACTICE OF
HUMAN KINDNESS. FIRST FEEL
COMPASSION FOR YOURSELF, AS YOU
SAY, THE FOLLOWING SILENTLY. MAY
I BE HEALED? MADE MY HEART
OPENED WITH KINDNESS AND PEACE.
MAY I BE FILLED WITH THE SPIRIT
OF LOVING KINDNESS? MAY I BE
WHOLE? NOW CALL TO MIND ALL WHO
COLLABORATE WITH YOU EACH DAY.
HEAR YOURSELF SAYING TO THEM.
MAY YOU BE HEALED YOUR HEART
OPEN WITH KINDNESS AND PEACE.
MAY YOU BE FILLED WITH THE
SPIRIT OF LOVING KINDNESS. MAY
YOU BEHOLD? FINALLY OPEN YOUR
HEART IN A SPECIAL WAY TO ALL
YOUR CONSTITUENTS AND LET YOUR
COMPASSION EXPAND EVEN TO OUR
WHOLE COUNTRY AND WORLD. AS YOU
SAY THEY ALL BEANS BE HEALED.
MAY ALL BEANS BE HAPPY. MAY ALL
BEANS BE TOUCHED AND HEALED BY
THE FORCE OF HUMAN KINDNESS. MAY
THE POWER OF OUR HEART. OUR
GOODNESS, OUR LOVE AND OUR
LEGISLATION BRING HEALING TO
ALL. AMEN. MEMBERS PLEASE JOIN
ME IN THE PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE
TO THE FLAG. I PLEDGE
ALLEGIANCE.
GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS. IT'S
NICE TO SEE EVERYONE BACK HERE
ON THE SENATE FLOOR. WE HAVE TWO
DISTINGUISHED GUESTS IN OUR
PRESENCE TODAY. I'D LIKE TO
INVITE THE SENATE TO GIVE A WARM
WELCOME BACK A WARM WELCOME BACK
TO SENATORS PAN AND SENATORS
HUFF. IT'S NICE TO SEE YOU BOTH
BACK HERE ON THE SENATE FLOOR.
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE NEXT TO
PRIVILEGES OF THE FLOOR. AND FOR
THAT WE'RE GOING TO TURN TO
SENATOR RUBIO. FOR PURPOSES OF
INTRODUCTION, SENATOR RUBIO
BEFORE YOU BEGIN. MEMBERS PLEASE
GIVE YOUR ATTENTION TO SENATOR
RUBIO, SENATOR RUBIO. THANK YOU,
MR PRESIDENT. AND LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN OF THE SENATE TODAY, I
WOULD LIKE TO WELCOME AND
INTRODUCE SOME MEMBERS OF THE
CALIFORNIA CONTRACT CITIES
ASSOCIATION WHO ARE HERE TODAY
IN OUR GALLERY. PLEASE ALLOW ME
TO INTRODUCE THE PRESIDENT. DR.
JULIAN GOLD MAYOR OF THE CITY OF
BEVERLY HILLS. THEIR IMMEDIATE
PAST PRESIDENT JEFF WOULD
COUNCIL MEMBER FROM THE CITY OF
LAKEWOOD EXECUTIVE BOARD MEMBER
SANDRA MENTHE COUNCIL MEMBER
FROM THE CITY OF ROSEMEAD.
JOHNNY GARCIA MAYOR PRO TEM OF
THE CITY OF PICO RIVERA,
CALIFORNIA CONTRACT CITIES
ASSOCIATION REPRESENTS 80 CITIES
IN LOS ANGELES COUNTY. AND THIS
WEEK THEY'RE ALL HERE FOR THEIR
LEGISLATIVE TOUR, AND I WANT TO
THANK THEM FOR THE WORK THEY DO
LOCALLY ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIANS MEMBERS. LET'S
PLEASE GIVE THEM A VERY WARM
WELCOME. THANK YOU. WELCOME TO
THE CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE.
WELCOME. MEMBERS MOVING ON TO
OUR AGENDA. MESSAGES FROM THE
GOVERNOR WILL BE DEEMED READ.
MESSAGES FROM THE ASSEMBLY WILL
BE DEEMED READ. REPORTS OF
COMMITTEE WILL BE DEEMED READ
AND AMENDMENTS ADOPTED. UNDER
MOTIONS, RESOLUTIONS AND NOTICES
. I DON'T SEE ANY MICROPHONES
UP. WE'LL MOVE NEXT TO
INTRODUCTIONS AND FIRST READING
OF BILL'S SECRETARY, PLEASE READ
. SENATE BILLS 908909 AND 19.
WE'RE GOING TO RETURN NOW TO
MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS. NOW IS
THE TIME TO ADDRESS ADJOURN IN
MEMORIES. FIRST UP FOR THE
SENATE PRESIDENT PRO TEM TONI
ATKINS. THANK YOU, MR PRESIDENT.
COLLEAGUES ARE RISE TODAY TO
ADJOURN IN MEMORY OF PETER'S
SEIDLER, HUMANITARIAN
PHILANTHROPIST AND THE CHAIRMAN
OF THE SAN DIEGO PADRES, WHO
PASSED AWAY NOVEMBER 14TH AT THE
VERY YOUNG AGE OF 63. PETER WAS
BORN TO TERRY SEIDLER AND ROLL
INSIDE LOR JUNIOR IN ALHAMBRA ON
NOVEMBER 7TH 1960. HE EARNED A
BACHELOR OF SCIENCE DEGREE IN
COMMERCE FROM THE UNIVERSITY OF
VIRGINIA IN CHARLOTTESVILLE AND
A MASTER OF BUSINESS
ADMINISTRATION DEGREE FROM THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA. LOS
ANGELES. U C L. A AFTER WORKING
IN THE LENDING ARM OF BANK OF
AMERICA, HE FOUNDED SEIDLER
EQUITY PARTNERS, A PRIVATE
EQUITY INVESTMENT FIRM IN 1992.
CREATING A VERY SUCCESSFUL
BUSINESS THAT NOW MANAGES MORE
THAN $5 BILLION IN ASSETS.
OWNING BASEBALL TEAMS RAN IN
PETER'S FAMILY. HIS GRANDFATHER,
WALTER O'MALLEY, OWNED THE
BROOKLYN DODGERS. AND MOVE THE
TEAM TO LOS ANGELES AND HIS
UNCLE, PETER O'MALLEY OWNED THE
CLUB UNTIL 1998. IN 2012 PETER
FOLLOWED THE FAMILY TRADITION
AND TOOK THE PLUNGE INTO TEAM
OWNERSHIP, PARTNERED WITH PETER
O'MALLEY AND RON FOWLER TO
PURCHASE THE SAN DIEGO PADRES
FROM JOHN MOORES. IN 2020, HE
BECAME CHAIRMAN OF THE BASEBALL
CLUB. HE PURSUED AN AGGRESSIVE
SPENDING APPROACH ACQUIRING STAR
PLAYERS WHO HELPED THE PADRES
REACHED THE PLAYOFFS IN 2022.
HIS LIFETIME DREAM WAS FOR THE
PADRES, OF COURSE TO WIN THE
WORLD SERIES. PETER'S LEGACY IN
SAN DIEGO, HOWEVER, FAR EXCEEDS
HIS PASSION FOR ESTABLISHING A
WINNING BASEBALL TEAM. HE IS
REMEMBERED FONDLY FOR HIS
SUPPORT OF PHILANTHROPIC CAUSES.
UNDER HIS TENURE, THE SAN DIEGO
PADRES FOUNDATION'S ANNUAL
GIVING EXPANDED BY 1000. HE WAS
ESPECIALLY DEVOTED TO THE CAUSE
OF ALLEVIATING HOMELESSNESS, AND
HE SERVED ON THE BOARD OF
DIRECTORS OF LUCKY DUCK
FOUNDATION, A SAN DIEGO
CHARITABLE ORGANIZATION
DEDICATED TO THAT EFFORT. HE
ALSO FORMED THE TUESDAY GROUP
AND ORGANIZATION OF BUSINESS AND
CIVIC LEADERS WHO WORKED ON
STRATEGIES TO SUPPORT THE
UNSHELTERED IN SAN DIEGO. PETER
WAS KNOWN REGULARLY TO WALK
THROUGH HOMELESS ENCAMPMENTS IN
THE EAST VILLAGE NEAR PETCO PARK
AND ALSO IN THE BEACH
COMMUNITIES NEAR HIS HOME, WHERE
HE WOULD TALK WITH PEOPLE
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS TO
BETTER LEARN WHAT COULD BE DONE
TO HELP EASE THEIR SUFFERING. HE
ALSO SUPPORTED MANY OTHER
CHARITIES, INCLUDING THE
JUVENILE DIABETES RESEARCH
FOUNDATION, THE AMERICAN CANCER
SOCIETY HOME START. WHICH WORKS
TO PREVENT CHILD ABUSE AND THE
MAYO CLINIC. HE AND HIS WIFE
SHIELD WERE FOUNDING MEMBERS OF
THE STAND UP TO CANCER LEGACY
ENDOWMENT CIRCLE. HE IS SURVIVED
BY HIS WIFE SEE ALL HIS THREE
CHILDREN, HIS MOTHER, TERRI
SADLER, AND NON SIBLINGS. HE WAS
AN INCREDIBLY GENTEEL PERSON.
ANYONE THAT MET HIM, UH, COULD
SEE THAT HE CARED DEEPLY ABOUT
THOSE LESS FORTUNATE AND WE WERE
LUCKY IN SAN DIEGO TO HAVE HIM
LEAD THE PADRES. I ASKED THAT WE
ADJOURNED TODAY IN MEMORY OF
PETER SADLER, A DYNAMIC,
GENEROUS, COMPASSIONATE, HUMBLE
AND ETERNALLY OPTIMISTIC MAN WHO
LEFT AN INDELIBLE IMPACT ON SAN
DIEGO AND ON CALIFORNIA. THANK
YOU PRO TEM ATKINS. PLEASE BRING
HIS NAME FORWARD SO HE CAN BE
PROPERLY MEMORIALIZED IN THE
SENATE JOURNAL. THANK YOU. LIKE
THE NEXT CALL ON SENATOR STERN.
THANK YOU, MR PRESIDENT. I WOULD
HAVE RISEN ON THE FIRST DAY BACK
. BUT THIS IS MY FIRST DAY BACK.
UM IN HONOR OF PAUL KESSLER,
CONSTITUENT OF MINE WHO WAS
KILLED NOVEMBER 5TH. IN WHAT I
WOULD CHARACTERIZE AS THE MOST
EGREGIOUS EXAMPLE OF THE
WEAPONIZATION OF FREE SPEECH
THAT WE'VE BEEN SEEING. OVER THE
LAST SEVERAL MONTHS. UM IN THIS
CASE, HE WAS LITERALLY STRUCK IN
THE FACE BY A MEGAPHONE. UM, AND
FELL BACK. HIT HIS HEAD AND DIED
A FEW HOURS LATER. UM HE WAS
THERE PROTESTING GROUP THAT WAS
AH! WAS PROTESTING ISRAEL. AND
FOR WEEKS HAD BEEN STANDING ON A
STREET CORNER OUTSIDE A GAS
STATION IN OUR DISTRICT. UM
SPEWING RHETORIC THAT WAS VERY
CLOSE TO THE LINE. INCITEMENT.
THERE IS SOME EVIDENCE THAT
FIREARMS WE EVEN BRANDISHED AND
SHOWN INTIMIDATION WAS CERTAINLY
A PART OF THIS, BUT ON THAT
PARTICULAR DAY. PAUL WAS
CARRYING AN ISRAELI FLAG. AND
WAS STANDING THERE WITH A FEW
OTHER CONSTITUENTS SPEAKING OUT.
THIS WAS ONLY LESS THAN A MONTH
AFTER OCTOBER 7TH I USE A
CONGREGATION MEMBER OF TEMPLE
IT'S TIME AND ACTUALLY GREW UP
IN SCRANTON, UM, NOT FAR FROM
FROM OUR PRESIDENT. BUT HAD BEEN
WORKING IN THE COMMUNITY FOR
YEARS AND PHILANTHROPIC ACTIVIST
HAD BEEN READING ABOUT THESE
THINGS ONLINE AND THOUGHT BETTER
GO OUT AND STAND UP. UM, THAT
GOT HIM KILLED. FINALLY THE D A
DECIDED TO ACTUALLY PRESS
CHARGES UNDER VOLUNTARY
MANSLAUGHTER, AND THEY'RE STILL
INVESTIGATING WHETHER THIS WAS A
HATE CRIME AS WELL. WE AS YOU
KNOW OF ENHANCED PENALTIES FOR
HATE CRIMES. AND IN THIS CASE,
HIS CLOSE ASSOCIATION WITH BEING
JEWISH UM AND BEING A TARGET AS
A RESULT. IT'S PART OF WHAT MY
VIEW GOT HIM KILLED. THIS IS A
DANGEROUS TIME FOR SPEECH. UM
THAT PUTS OUR OWN MEMBERS AT
RISK ON A DAILY BASIS. STANDING
HERE LOOKING AT MY COLLEAGUE
FROM SAN FRANCISCO. UH WHO TAKES
SOME OF THE MOST VICIOUS AND
NASTY ATTACKS YOU CAN POSSIBLY
IMAGINE DAILY ON THE INTERNET
HAS TO SORT OF BRUSH IT OFF JUST
AS FREE SPEECH AND THAT'S X
BEING X. UM, BUT SPEECH. CROSS
THE LINE. THAT MEGAPHONE BECAME
A WEAPON. PAUL IS GONE AS A
RESULT. OUR COMMUNITY IS
MOURNING. I HOPE WE ALL ADJOURN
IN HIS MEMORY. AND RESOLVE
OURSELVES. THAT WHEN WE USE OUR
VOICES THAT WE KNOW. THE EFFECT.
OF THAT SPEECH, AND WE KNOW WHO
WE CAN HARM AND WE KNOW WHO WE
CAN SET OFF AND WE KNOW THAT
PEOPLE'S LIVES ARE LITERALLY AT
STAKE, AND WE'RE NOT TALKING
ABOUT OVERSEAS WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT RIGHT HERE ON OUR OWN
SOIL. SO THANK YOU FOR TAKING A
MINUTE TO REMEMBER PAUL. AND I
HOPE HIS LEGACY IS ONE OF PEACE
AND OF COMEDY. KIND OF
TOGETHERNESS. AND A REJECTION OF
THIS KIND OF HATRED IN OUR
COMMUNITIES. THANK YOU, SENATOR
STERN. PLEASE BRING HIS NAME
FORWARD SO WE CAN BE PROPERLY
MEMORIALIZED IN THE SENATE
JOURNAL. LIKE THE NEXT CALL ON
SENATOR DURAZO. THANK YOU, MR MR
SPEAKER, MR PRESIDENT. ON THE
THIRD DAY OF CHRISTMAS LAST
DECEMBER. 27TH NATIONAL ASANO JR
PASSED AWAY SURROUNDED BY HIS
CHILDREN AND GRANDCHILDREN AT
HIS DAUGHTER, MONICA, A FRIEND
OF MINE AT THEIR HOME NATURAL
ASANO, MOST WIDELY KNOWN FOR
DECADES AS PUBLISHER AND
CHAIRMAN OF THE COUNTRY'S
LARGEST SPANISH LANGUAGE,
NEWSPAPER, LA OPINION. WAS LAID
TO REST IN ORANGE COUNTY. THE
OTHER LOW RES ALONGSIDE HIS
BELOVED LATE WIFE, MARTHA. HE
WOULD HAVE TURNED 97 NEXT MONDAY
. MANY OF US HAVE PERSONALLY
KNOWN AND ADMIRED THE LAW SANO
FAMILY FOR MANY YEARS. I'M
TAKING THE OPPORTUNITY TO HONOR
NACHO AND HIS LIFE'S WORK AND
MAKE A LITTLE, UH, BETTER KNOWN
THE ROLE OF HIS AND HIS FAMILY'S
DAILY NEWSPAPER OPINION OF LOS
ANGELES IN THE MAKING NOT ONLY
LIVE SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA'S
LATINO COMMUNITY, BUT MODERN
CALIFORNIA ITSELF. IN OUR STATE
IS TO KNOW THE ROLE OF MASS
MEDIA. TWO IN THE NEWS MEDIA
NEWSPAPERS IN PARTICULAR TO
FAMILIES ARE TAKEN AS
HISTORICALLY CENTRAL, THE HEARSE
AND THE COMBINED NOTICE AND
CHANDLER FAMILIES. THIS IMAGE
INCLUDES NORTH AND SOUTH SOUTH
FRANCISCO AND L A BUT LEAVES OUT
MOST OF LATINO, CALIFORNIA. THE
STORY OF THE LOS ANGELES IN THE
SOUTHWESTERN US BEGAN WITH
NACHOS IMMIGRANT FATHER DON
IGNACIO LOZANO. HE FOUNDED HIS
FIRST PAPER IN SAN ANTONIO 1913.
PRENSA ALONGSIDE THE LIBRARY, A
LAW SANO NEXT DOOR, WHICH IS A
BOOKSTORE. BOTH THE CENTER OF
MEXICO, MEXICAN SAN ANTONIO
SOCIAL AND POLITICAL LIFE.
IGNACIO LAUNCH LOBBYING YONA LOS
ANGELES ON THE 16TH OF
SEPTEMBER, 1926. UM HE LOCATED
HIS SECOND DAILY PAPER IN THE
DOWNTOWN OF MEXICAN LOS ANGELES
AT THAT TIME NORTH MAIN STREET
WITH ITS OWN LIVING AREA,
ROSSANO NEXT DOOR. THE LIVING
AREA WAS MORE THAN A UNIQUE
BOOKSTORE. IT ALSO PUBLISHED
ORIGINAL WORKS OF LITERARY
MERIT. DURING THE MASTER
REPATRIATIONS OF MEXICANS AND
MEXICAN AMERICANS AND THE EARLY
19 THIRTIES. THOSE ZOOT SUIT
RIOTS OF 1943, BOTH LA PRENSA
AND TEXAS AND LA OPINION
SUFFERED DEVASTATING LOSSES OF
CIRCULATION. NEITHER PAPER HAD
FULLY RECOVERED WHEN DON IGNACIO
PASSED AWAY, THE FOUNDER IN 1953
NATURAL, HIS SON TOOK OVER THE
STILL DIMINISHED LA OPINION
WHILE HIS MOTHER RAN UP AT INSA
IN TEXAS. ONLY LOBENDAHN UNDER
NATURAL LEADERSHIP SURVIVED THE
19 FIFTIES AND FULLER RECOVERED
BY THE 19 SEVENTIES, WHEN HE
RETIRED ON THE 60TH ANNIVERSARY
OF THE NEWSPAPERS FOUNDING. IT
WAS NOT ONLY THE LARGEST SPANISH
LANGUAGE NEWSPAPER IN THE
COUNTRY, BUT THE FASTEST GROWING
US PAPER IN ANY LANGUAGE.
NATURAL LOZANO'S LOBENDAHN
NATURALLY COVERED AND GAVE
PROMINENCE TO STORIES AND
DEVELOPMENTS IN MEXICO, LATIN
AMERICA AND THE LATINO
COMMUNITY. THAT WENT UNMENTIONED
IN US MAINSTREAM MEDIA. BUT ALSO
DIFFERENT IN A DEEPER WAY. WHILE
IN THEIR EARLY YEARS, THE HEARST
NEWSPAPERS AND THE L A TIMES
WERE EAGER PROMOTERS OF US
MILITARY INTERVENTION IN LATIN
AMERICA AND THE PHILIPPINES.
NATURAL PERSONALLY IN HIS
NEWSPAPER EMPHASIZE THE NEED FOR
DEMOCRACY AND THE FREEDOM OF THE
PRESS. HE BECAME CLOSE TO THE
NEWSPAPER OWNING FAMILIES OF
LATIN AMERICA AND WAS ELECTED
PRESIDENT OF THE INTER AMERICAN
PRESS ASSOCIATION AND DESIGNATED
U. S. AMBASSADOR TO EL SALVADOR
BY PRESIDENT FORD. ALL FOUR MR
LOZANO'S CHILDREN WORKED OUT
LOUD BEING YOUNG AT ONE TIME OR
ANOTHER, WITH THE THREE OLDEST
UH, SURVIVING SERVING AS
PUBLISHER OR CORE PUBLISHER OF
LIFELONG REPUBLICAN NATURAL, WAS
STILL CHAIRMAN OF LOUD BINION
BOARD IN 1994 WHEN THEN GOVERNOR
PETE WILSON ENDORSED AND RAN ON
THE NOTORIOUSLY ANTI IMMIGRANT
PROPOSITION 187 AS PART OF HIS
REELECTION. THAT LED NACHO TO
CHANGE HIS PARTY RESIGNATION
REGISTRATION AND THEREAFTER
CALLED HIMSELF A PETE WILSON,
DEMOCRAT. IT IS IMPOSSIBLE TO
CAPTURE NACHO LOS ANILLOS LIFE
IN THESE REMARKS HE WAS FAR TOO
ACTIVE AND MULTIFACETED FOR
THAT. AMONG THE MANY CORPORATE
AND NONPROFIT BOARDS HE SERVED
ON. HE WAS ESPECIALLY PASSIONATE
ABOUT EDUCATION AND HIS ALMA
MATER, NOTRE DAME, WHERE HE AND
HIS WIFE ESTABLISHED A
SCHOLARSHIP PROGRAM FOR LATINO
STUDENTS. HE RAISED CARS IN HIS
YOUTH PILOTED HIS OWN PLANES,
WAS AN AVID GOLFER, SAILOR
SHOOTER. AND A MAN OF FAITH, A
FAMILY MAN. WHO ENJOYED DEEP
FRYING TURKEYS AND WHO SHIPPED
HIS OWN GRILL TO THE U. S
AMBASSADOR'S RESIDENCE IN SAN
SALVADOR. HE WAS APPROPRIATE. IT
WAS APPROPRIATE TO NOTE AS I
BEGAN THAT NATURAL PAST AND WAS
ENTERED DURING THE 12 DAYS OF
CHRISTMAS. HE WAS TRULY A MAN OF
FAITH. HIS FATHER'S REMAINS WERE
TRANSFERRED TO THE BASILICA
DELLA VIGNA GUADALUPE IN MEXICO
CITY. HE ATTENDED ALL CATHOLIC
SCHOOLS HIMSELF, AS DID HIS AND
MARTHA'S CHILDREN. HE WAS A U. S
PATRIOT AS WELL AS A PROUD SON
OF MEXICO. NATURAL HIS FAMILY
AND NEWSPAPER HELPED FASHION
LATINOS OF MULTIPLE GENERATIONS,
DIFFERENT NATIONAL ORIGINS AND
LIVING SPREAD WIDELY ACROSS
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA INTO A
COMMUNITY THAT FINALLY ACHIEVED
REPRESENTATION IN THIS CAPITAL
IN LOCAL AND NATIONAL GOVERNMENT
AND A WIDE RANGE OF US
INSTITUTIONS. WE OURSELVES IN A
REAL SENSE ARE PART OF HIS
LEGACY. HIS PRECEDED IN DEATH IN
2018 BY MARTIN NAVARRO, HIS WIFE
OF 67 YEARS. YOU SURVIVED BY HIS
DAUGHTER'S MONICA, CECILIA,
LUCIANO LETICIA LUCIANO, HIS
SONS, JOSE LOZANO AND FRANCISCO
ANTONIO LOZANO AND NINE CHILDREN
, GRANDCHILDREN. COLLEAGUES
PLEASE JOIN ME IN SENDING OUR
DEEPEST CONDOLENCES TO HIS
FAMILY. WHERE THE TREMENDOUS
LOSS RISKS IN PODEROSO SENOR
IGNACIO LUCIANO JUNIOR. THANK
YOU, SENATOR DURAZO ON THIS
ADJOURNED IN MEMORY NEXT, WANNA
RECOGNIZE SENATOR ALLEN? MEMBERS
I WANT TO JOIN IN THIS A JOURNEY
MEMORY. I WAS UNDERGRADUATE WHO
DID MY THESIS AND U. S HISTORY
LARGELY BASED ON COVERAGE FROM
HELPING YOUNG BACK IN THE
FIFTIES AND SIXTIES, AND I GOT
TO EXPERIENCE FIRSTHAND THROUGH
HOURS AND HOURS OF RESEARCH.
WEEKS AND WEEKS, MONTHS AND
MONTHS, COMPARING THIS THIS
UNIQUE SOURCE OF AMERICAN
HISTORY UNDER NATURAL LOZANO'S
LEADERSHIP OPINION, ABSOLUTELY
PROVIDED A VERY DIFFERENT
PERSPECTIVE ON AMERICAN NEWS ON
CALIFORNIA NEWS, THEN THE LOS
ANGELES TIMES LOS ANGELES TIMES
REALLY SHIFTED IN THE IN THE
LATE 19 SIXTIES TO BECOME A VERY
DIFFERENT PAPER. BUT AT THE TIME
, THE OPINION PROVIDED A VERY
SPECIAL PERSPECTIVE. UH AND IT
AND, OF COURSE NATURAL. ASANO
OVERSAW THIS TRANSITION FROM
BEING A LATIN AMERICAN PAPER
THAT WAS VERY MUCH FOCUSED ON
LATIN AMERICAN NEWS. AND LATIN
AMERICAN PERSPECTIVES TO AN
AMERICAN PAPER THAT JUST
HAPPENED TO BE PUBLISHED IN
SPANISH, AND IT'S SERVED AN
ENORMOUS POPULATION OF SPANISH
SPEAKERS WHO, YES, WANTED TO
KNOW THE NEWS FROM THE COUNTRIES
FROM WHICH THEY COME OR THEIR
PARENTS HAD COME. BUT THEY ALSO
IT WAS, IT BECAME INCREASINGLY
NEWS THAT WAS VERY MUCH BASED ON
THE CHALLENGES AND NEEDS OF THE
LATINO COMMUNITY. IN LOS ANGELES
AND ELSEWHERE. UM HE HE LEADS AN
EXTRAORDINARY LEGACY. UH AND I
DO WANT TO ALSO JUST SEND A VERY
PERSONAL NOTE OF CONDOLENCE TO
WONDERFUL PUBLIC SERVANT IN HER
OWN RIGHT MONICA LAW SANO, WHO
SERVED ON THE BOARD OF REGIONS
AND MANY OTHER PUBLIC
CAPACITIES. SHE'S OBVIOUSLY HIS
HIS DAUGHTER AND WAS WAS THE CEO
AND PUBLISHER OF THE OPINION AS
WELL. THIS IS A SPECIAL MAN, AN
IMPORTANT FIGURE IN CALIFORNIA
HISTORY, AND I JOIN IN ASKING
THAT WE JOINED HIS MEMORY. THANK
YOU, SENATOR ALLEN. SENATOR
DURAZO, IF YOU COULD BRING HIS
NAME FORWARD SO HE CAN BE
PROPERLY MEMORIALIZED IN THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE JOURNAL.
NUMBERS IF THERE'S NOTHING ELSE
UNDER MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS,
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE TO COMMITTEE
ANNOUNCEMENTS. WE HAVE ONE. WHEN
I CALL ON SENATOR ALVARADO GUILT
THANK YOU. THE HUMAN SERVICES
COMMITTEE WILL MEET, UM,
PROMPTLY UPON ADJOURNMENT IN
ROOM 2100. THANK YOU, SENATOR.
SEE NO OTHER BUSINESS BEFORE THE
HOUSE, SENATOR ATKINS, THE DESK
IS CLEAR. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
MR PRESIDENT. COLLEAGUES ARE
NEXT FLOOR SESSION IS SCHEDULED
FOR THIS FRIDAY, NOT THURSDAY,
FRIDAY, JANUARY 12TH 2024 AT
NINE PM THE SENATE WILL BE IN
RECESS UNTIL 330 PM, AT WHICH
TIME THE GERMAN MOTION WILL BE
MADE. WE WILL RECONVENE FRIDAY
AT 9 A.M. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
MEMBERS HAVE A VERY NICE REST OF
YOUR DAY.